et
au coeur du continent africain
la forêt équatoriale s'étend sur une
zone immense qui recouvre aussi pays
il estime que les tribus pygmées sont
arrivés dans la jungle au nord de
l'actuelle rdc près de vingt mille ans
avant notre ère à l'issue d'une
mystérieuse migration histoire des
pygmées se perd dans la nuit des temps
mais on sait qu'ils furent graduellement
réduit en esclavage par les tribus
bantou qui va s'installer dans la forêt
après bien plus tard l'exploitation du
bois par l'écolo et la destruction
croissante de leur habitat naturel
accentue encore la marginalisation des
pygmées les plus audacieux d'entre eux
tempère alors le voyage vers la grande
ville en quête d'une vie meilleure
parmi eux wendy l'open ya un pygmée de
la tribu des battoirs
aïe je m'appelle huang il oppose un bel
hommage à l'art même après dans ma forêt
en 1961 et tintin c'est comme ça que
j'ai quitté mon village on est passé par
ici roa par bomback dont tous les pays
un faisait tout le temps la guerre et
puis on est arrivé à kinshasa
minutes
par les soldats symbole du bir alors
j'ai déserté l'armée et j'ai su rester à
kinshasa et macky sall
moi nous a obligés d'aimer des bruits et
seulement je voyais des les autres
piques n'est tous et qui galérait envie
j'essuie willow ponia below mais j'ai
sucé l'équipe tous les pays nous tous et
qui débarque à kinshasa des quatre coins
de la forêt c'est moi qui le recueille
ils savent tous ce qui je suis mwangi
l'open yabi l'onu
on
c'est en 2008 que nous rencontrons wang
îlots ponia et sa femme solide pour la
première fois nous découvrons un couple
pudique est complice ils se sont
rencontrés dix ans auparavant à kinshasa
et ne se sont plus quittés
ensemble ils font face à la misère
réelle indescriptible chaos de cette
ville de 10 millions d'habitants
leur détermination dans le combat qu'il
mène pour la reconnaissance des droits
des pygmées nous impressionne mais après
trente ans passés au ghetto les espoirs
de willow ponia commence à s'évanouir
enlever tous venir en ville kinshasa
c'est l'europe noah mines ou les pygmées
de la forêt on voit kinshasa comme des
rocs
mais quand on arrive ici il rêve
s'écroule
il n'ya pas absolument aucun droit par
rapport à un bond entre nous et eux il
ya cette inégalité ancestrales ça vient
de très loin du temps de nos ancêtres et
aujourd'hui la situation n'a pas changé
nous sommes toujours leurs exploits les
pygmées sont toujours ceux qui font les
basses besognes
c'est la condition du python pour nous
des rentrées pour travailler notre terre
là bas il n'y a pas de matériel pas du
tout quand on aura réuni assez d'outils
ici on rentrera chez l'homme avec tout
ce qu'on sait faire
quand ça sortira très bien on
travaillera pour nous mêmes les batwa
pour le [__]
et puis je voudrais temps et voir mon
fils qui est laissée au pire il est
toujours là bas dans la forêt
lorsque wendy a quitté sa famille les
anciens du village leur mine statuette
rituel qui disait s'ils le protègerait
dans les combats et ferait de lui un
guide pour les autres pygmées où qu'ils
soient et sept statuettes devait revenir
un jour à ses descendants rester dans la
forêt wang y en avait fait le serment
mes ancêtres m'ont laissé ses statuts
elle lui c'est l'ancêtre du sambo voyez
comme il est ligoté
ça ressemble à notre situation à nous
les batwa qui défiera tous ces liens
tous ces liens qui nous entrave
malgré le mal du pays qui le ronge wang
yi a choisi de continuer à se battre à
kinshasa car il n'envisage pas de
rentrer au village sans avoir obtenu des
résultats dans la cause qu'ils défendent
voici mon projet dos à dieu c'est le
plan d'une coopérative gérée par les
pigments
il faut en créer dans la région dé
kinshasa et une autre chez nous au
village les aides destinées aux pygmées
sont détournés ou et les sanctuaires qui
nous ont promis et les logements qu'ils
ont promis aux pygmées où part l'argent
récolté à notre nom je dois réaliser ses
projets moi mais ça doit exister un
anneau en flat ya ce n'est pas pour
aujourd'hui
pour le moment je n'ai pas de moyens
mais j'y arriverais nous ferons cela
nous mêmes nous les battures pas nous
les pigments de la forêt équatoriale
vous
deux ans plus tard rien n'a changé et la
coopérative pygmées dont rêvait wayne
qui n'a jamais vu le jour
wendy qui sont ces forces diminuent et a
pris la décision de rentrer chez lui
nous a contacté et nous a proposé de
filmer son retour dans son village natal
un retour qu'il imagine porteur d'espoir
pour les siens nous avons accepté sa
proposition
nous retrouvons wendy et celui à
kinshasa mais pendant les préparatifs du
voyage la santé de wendy se dégradent
brutalement comme je suis chômeur je
n'ai pas l'argent pour me soigner
je ne vais pas me mettre à voler
aujourd'hui la maladie m'a attrapé alors
je prends le médicament de nos ancêtres
si ça ne marche pas gérer à l'hôpital
je ne réalise pas la médecine de blanc
là on ne trouve pas nos médicaments à
kinshasa
nos armes ne sont pas si j'étais à
bocapôle à la maladie ne pourrons pas
nous tuer j'aurai dans la forêt et je me
soignerai directement mais où trouver
nos arbres à kinshasa comment soigner
son corps
quinze jours après notre arrivée à
kinshasa et malgré tous nos efforts wang
îlots paulien meurt d'une tuberculose
qui n'avait jamais soigné il s'éteint
sans avoir pu revoir son fils ni honorer
la promesse qu'il avait faite à ses
ancêtres
pour ses funérailles toute la communauté
pygmée de kinshasa s'est donné rendez
vous pour rendre un dernier hommage au
vieux chef
m
pour celui c'est une perte immense mais
elle fait face avec courage et semblent
animés d'une force que nous ne
connaissions pas
le
nous sommes bouleversés par la perte de
notre ami et nous réalisons peu à peu
que le film que wendy avait tant voulu
n'a désormais plus de raison d'être
mais une semaine plus tard alors que
nous sommes sur le point de rentrer en
france
ce il convoque chez wendy car elle a une
révélation importante à nous faire
oh
la lune je suis venu chercher wendy
quand il était 5 heures il dormait ici
tout seul quand je suis rentré dans la
pièce on aurait dit qu'il était déjà
mort j'ai eu vraiment peur
j'ai crié son nom trois fois et il a
fini par se réveiller
il était tout nu dans son lit en creux
l'hôtel j'ai dû la bille et moi même
ensuite je les levées et on est sortis
d'ici je l' ai traîné pour prendre un
taxi vers l'hôpital
c'est tout un testament qu'il m'a laissé
sur son lit de mort
les dernières volontés des remords on ne
peut pas blague à l'aise c'est moi soyez
cette corde auto c'est moi et personne
d'autre
je vis avec l'esprit de wendy en moins
on m'a donné une mission doit ramener la
statuette à son fils qui est restée au
village
tant que je ne l'aurai pas fait je ne
serait pas libéré de son esprit c'était
ses dernières volontés
quand tu crois nous partirons tous avec
toi
ne t'inquiète pas accompli la volonté du
vieux nous tous suivent n'écoute pas les
mauvaises langues ne te laisse pas
détourner ce qui compte c'est la volonté
de mj
le poids d'une telle responsabilité est
énorme pour celui quitter la ville sans
wayne qui n'est pas une chose aisée se
hisser qu'elle va devoir laisser le peu
qu'elle a construit à kinshasa pour
l'inconnu d'un périple sur le reste
fleuve congo est la promesse faite à
wendy et plus fortes promesses pour
promesses nous décidons de respecter la
nôtre est de suivre solide dans son
voyage en quête du fils de wayne guy tu
veux du pain si tu veux de la patte de
la racine il faut payer un supplément
aujourd'hui au combat il n'y a plus rien
de gratuit l'économie a évolué tu as un
train de retard mon pote
aujourd'hui le bleu n'a rien rapporté
un terme à voir papa talibane a fait
cadeau dit
quand on m'a envoyait kinshasa j'étais
vraiment contente
est ce que je voulais c'était quitté ma
jungle et découvrir la vie mais la vie a
été tout de suite difficile ici
j'habitais chez un maître bontoux un
oncle éloigné voulez que je fasse le
trottoir tout cela m'était très pénible
je suis resté longtemps à son service
j'étais sa bonne à tout faire mais lui
et sa femme ils ne me payaient jamais il
ne me donnait rien à manger
je supportais ça parce que je n'avais
nulle part d'autre où aller quand j'ai
rencontré ou une vie il avait déjà son
orchestre
on s'est rencontrés par la musique il
m'a dit rejoint notre groupe à l'époque
plein de pitt mais je vais déjà chez
on se retrouvait tous si oui pour
chanter notre tradition les musiques il
jouait le moi je les connaissais déjà du
village je suis rentré facilement dans
le rythme c'était dans mon sens à partir
de là willy et moi on est tombé amoureux
et c'est comme ça que je suis venu
habiter chez vous des dégâts qu'en toute
fin de mercato et pas à bout france
m
moi je ne ferais pas ce voyage avec le g
vient trop de choses à accomplir ici à
kinshasa
je me suis fixé des objectifs et je veux
des résultats
je dois suivre ma voie à kinshasa je
sens que mon heure arrive moi aussi un
jour rentrer au village
mais ce jour là je me souviendrai aux
besoins de ma famille ils diront alors
roi david est parti à kinshasa
mais aujourd'hui il est revenu pour nous
sauver les autres vont rentrer au pays
ils ont fait le choix de quitter
kinshasa c'est une bonne chose et de
retourner au village celui à une mission
à remplir en même temps ils vont
rechercher leur mémoire là bas ils vont
aussi retrouver l'esprit des anciens
et quand il reviendra à kinshasa ils
seront plus forts
mais très complet moussavi
vous
non
or
l'un d'eux me -10 est mort physiquement
je me sens esprit vit toujours en soins
on s'était promis de faire ce voyage
ensemble
son corps est mort mais son esprit
voyagera avec moi je sais qu'ils me
disent ah
à force de persévérance et grâce au
soutien des autres pygmées que wayne qui
avait aidé soyez ses compagnons en
barque sur une barge de marchandises ils
vont enfin parcourir les 800 kilomètres
qui séparent kinshasa de la grande forêt
équatoriale c'est la première fois qu'il
retourne au village
serviable
au final
bd
quand rdc le réseau routier est en ruine
et les avions inaccessible pour une
population dont le salaire moyen est de
20 dollars
le fleuve congo est donc le seul moyen
de remonter au nord du pays mais les
bateaux surchargés sont vétustes et le
fleuve imprévisible l'appréhension de
souilhe et de ses compagnons est
palpable
nul ne sait combien de temps prendra le
voyage à mesure que nous avançons so i
semble plonger à l'intérieur d'elle-même
elle est comme absente au milieu de la
couille
m
il y a
nous sommes des commerçants donc c'est
vraiment sur ce bateau fond sa passion
vient en fait du commerce entre la ville
et le village et nourrir nos enfants en
vend nos marchandises en chemin on
achète du poisson du manioc
oui on retombe ventes ça en ville et on
recommence ton léger nous sommes dans le
désert nous espérons atteindre la terre
promise
comment
le convoi de près de 200 mètres de long
avance au ralenti depuis maintenant près
de 12 jours nous n'avons pas recours et
que 300 kilomètres à peine la moitié du
chemin au fil des jours
la barge prend des allures de camp de
réfugiés et pour se lier les siens
l'arrivée dans le village de wailly est
encore un rêve lointain mano provisions
ses prix ça va faire deux semaines
connaît sur ce bateau ça devient pénible
avec un bateau normal on serait déjà
loin nous on a déjà filmé nos provisions
ce bateau pourri a pris trop de retard
c'est la saison sèche
le niveau de l'eau est vraiment trop bas
du coup le bateau n'avance pas c'est ça
le problème
s'ils naviguaient jour et nuit on serait
déjà loin certains pensent qu'on est
presque on est loin de voler
chance avant comme après t'être dimanche
au président ben ali t il
on vient me croiser un bateau à l'eau
les gens de ce bateau nous ont dit de ne
rien vous acheter c'est pas grave
l'important c'est de vivre
ils disent que chez vous il ya une
épidémie de choléra il ya eu une
épidémie
là maintenant c'est fini il ya eu des
morts oui mais les derniers malades sont
traités à l'hôpital
l'épidémie a duré trois semaines en tout
il ya eu 40 aux morts en trois semaines
maintenant c'est fini
certains disent que c'est fini d'autres
soutiennent le contraire
finalement qui doit comme ça même vous
les auteurs vous ne dites pas la vérité
tous
dan ont accosté nice
il n'est plus question d'accoster à
nouveau la bague ya trop de risques de
manama beaucoup de gens meurent dans
quantum et demain on passe par un large
de bolobo il ya peut-être une épidémie
importante
oui ça se pourrait bien ça fait
longtemps qu'ils sont bloqués là et on
dormir là
y'a pas de plaisir à aux anneaux et moi
et moi des fois vous avez peur de nous
alors que ce évoqué contaminer l'autre
battant n'a pas voulu sa marraine au
bout ils ont dit que l'épidémie était
chez vous est ce que vous l'avez
la rdc info pays dans ce pays a trop de
souffrance regard de ces bateaux c'est
une part on est encore en panne ici à
kinshasa il ya selon celles 100 km et ça
nous a pris trois mois
le mou sans les droits de l'homme dans
ce pays
nous sommes un peuple de galérien pour
remonter ce fleuve l'état de revin de
combats tôt mais au lieu de ça en coule
à pic
dans la tradition de nos ancêtres si un
homme est mort loin de son village
un autre pic mais doit rapporter ses
effets personnels à sa famille nos
balles ouais il y tenait cette statuette
de son père elle doit maintenant revenir
à son fils c'est un poids énorme duquel
je dois me libérer j'ai peur de
rencontrer le fils de wade
ce fils que je ne voyais pas comment
va-t-il m'accueillir moi le mot portées
contre lui annoncerait la mort de son
père dans mon époux et d'essais libres
et open
après 20 jours de navigation le convoi
touche enfin au but
bamba k la capitale de la région de
l'équateur aux portes de la jeune sophie
ses amis sont exténués mais pour eux
c'est un autre voyage qui commence celui
qui doit les mener jusqu'au village
natal de m
nicolas a aussi financé
so in négocié deux jours après l'arrivée
à mende lac à notre petite troupe g dans
un taxi brousse pour remonter 180 km de
pistes au coeur de la forêt équatoriale
mais au départ de bamba k nul ne sait si
nous retrouverons le fils de wade
et
un ordre là regardez moi cette route et
vous allez encore voter pour eux notre
région se meurt et vous continuez à
leurs données ne voient ils viennent
juste pour prendre nos votes et nos
arrêts il se tire
normalement la pop les arbres ça devrait
développer la région sont venus nous
voir tout ce qu'ils possédaient des
forêts familiale ils nous ont obligé à
signer des papiers de décharge à lui et
à toute la famille il leur en donner
deux vélos plus un carton savant et un
sac de sucre
ils ont coupé vraiment beaucoup d'arbres
te veulent ou pour la famille entière
c'est peu
les gens de la compagnie nous disait
vous n'avez qu'à porter plainte mais
nous on est des gens de la forêt on ne
porte pas plainte contre les autorités
ils prennent aux arbres de force un
pauvre qui vit dans la forêt il peut pas
porter plainte
au fil des villages qui passe sous leurs
yeux les compagnons de saucisson de
reprendre des forces
nous remontons vers le nord nous ne
savons pas précisément se trouve l'île
échos le village natal de wind u100 nous
en avertir
celui demande au chauffeur de faire un
détour nous bifurquons vers l'ouest et
faisons halte à et tout cola le village
natal de souris pour y passer la nuit
non
c'est un imprévu de plus dans ce voyage
alors qu'elle s'éloigne dans les bras de
sa soeur vigneron ce que cela a sur le
coeur mais nous avons l'intuition
qu'elle souhaite se replonger dans son
propre passé avant d'aller à la
rencontre de celui de son mari
cela fait douze ans que ce il n'a pas
revu les siens
ma petite vie ça fait tant d'années que
je ne t'ai vu nos ancêtres taux ramenés
jusqu'à nous nos ancêtres c'est
bienveillant qui aurait cru que je te
reverrai un jour la route est vraiment
longue depuis kinshasa contre voyage
n'est pas fini je dois remonter au no tu
vas dans la famille son mari
oui tu es à peine arrivé que tu repars
déjà je dois me remettre en route demain
demain déjà
quand notre mère est morte je m'étais là
quand je pense qu'ils l'ont assassiné
parce qu'il ya eu une enquête
non il n'y a pas eu d' enquête
et pourquoi à qui faut tjrs et demandé
une enquête ici ta petite soeur effet
avec air continent tu à l'époque elle ne
savait pas encore parlé maintenant elle
ne se souvient plus de rien ce qui se
passe dans la forêt reste dans la forêt
pourtant elle a assisté au meurtre de
notre mère ce sont des bons tout qui ont
tué ma mère il en force c'est avoir de
l'acide au fond de la forêt elle est
morte d'une façon vraiment pour moi
c'est très douloureux de penser à ça je
réfléchis bien les meurtres de pygmées
sont monnaie courante par ici c'est
presque normal
un pic mais n'a aucune possibilité de se
défendre la mère s'était attiré beaucoup
de jalousie paris son mari était mort
mais elle voulait se débrouiller toute
seule elle refusait de se remarier pour
nous protéger
elle repoussait les avances des autres
hommes il en tue pour ça
jamais jusqu'ici ce in avait évoqué ce
drame lorsque sa mère a été assassinée
ce y vivaient déjà à kinshasa nous
comprenons alors que dans le long voyage
qu'elle a entrepris elle avait un autre
deuil à accomplir on la regarde en
défricher la sépulture de sa mère nous
nous disons que la situation des pygmées
est bien pire que nous l'imaginions pour
ce peuple spolié de sa terre réduits en
esclavage est considérée comme
inférieure par les autres ethnies
le combat mené va bien au delà de la
défense de leur environnement
no
hu
pour les pygmées la forêt était
autrefois un garde manger et une
pharmacie à ciel ouvert mais avec la
coupe du bois le gibier a disparu même
les arbres à chauny première source de
protéines pour les pygmées sont coupés
sans aucun contrôle plus les arbres
disparaissent plus les connaissances
traditionnelles s'efface des mémoires
bois rares pois rouges au bois noir un
arbre de 30 mètres s'achète 5 $ dans la
forêt il se revendre à 1000 $ à kinshasa
combien se vendre at-il en europe une
fois conditionné pourtant pour les
populations de cette partie du congo
il n'y a ni école ni hôpitaux
missionnaire bateau mais les
missionnaires en creusé cette route pour
arriver jusqu'à nous ensuite les
exploitants sont arrivés on a vu notre
forêt sont allés sur leur camion
on s'est assis là et on les a regardés
faire 10 europe et nous autres des
pygmées de voka thomas higgins on est
devenu des pygmées du bord de la route
nous ne savons même pas quelle route est
la nôtre
nous ne sommes plus qu'à 40 km de lille
échos le village natal de wade mais à
partir d'ici il n'y a plus de routes
praticables
juste une piste ces derniers kilomètres
où les parcours ont donc à vélo c'est
tout
après trois semaines de navigation sur
le fleuve congo et plus d'une semelle de
piste au coeur de la jungle ce ive enfin
accomplir la promesse qu'elle avait
faite à wendy nous réalisons qu'elle est
à bout de force
pour elle c'est l'heure de vérité winky
ouais c'est le moment de me donner ta
force cette tâche si lourde pour toi qui
vit à l'intérieur de moi donne moi la
force d'aller vers ces gens que je ne
connais pas et qui ne savent pas qui je
suis fait qu'ils écoutent ce que j'ai à
leur dire
j'ai apporté une photo de ton père
voici les radios de tempère on les a
faites à l'hôpital sur la première radio
on voit ses poumons
et voilà la deuxième ça tu appartiens
ton père est mort le 11 et mois de
l'année va faire 2 mois de ça j'étais
avec lui jusqu'à la fin il me parlait
toujours de toi ne t'avais pas jardin il
m'a demandé de venir te remettre ses
affaires et j'ai tenu parole
j'aimais sujet a presque plus de lui
mais dans mon coeur il est toujours là
il est toujours là tu es venu en son nom
et je dois mais résume ces soirs nous
avons le pleurer ensemble nous allons
plairait mon père c'est mon père qui t'a
envoyé
je ne peux pas la fusée sa volonté je
sais que tu as fait un très long voyage
et à fallait du courage pour arriver
jusqu'ici
j'ignorais qu'il était mort mais toi tu
es veniant son nom nous avons quitté
kinshasa depuis 35 jours
soyez transfiguré elle a tenu sa
promesse et par miracle diawara le fils
de wendy étaient présents à ce rendez
vous que nul n'avait fixé soleil
s'apprête enfin à se libérer de l'esprit
de wang en remettant la statuette là son
fils
wing il nous disait souvent que chaque
arbre de la forêt portel l'âme d'un
pygmées mort pour la première fois
depuis le début de l' aventure nous
ressentons physiquement la présence de
notre amie dans la nuit de la grande
forêt équatoriale quelque chose de
surnaturel est en train de se produire
quelque chose d'indicible dont nous nous
souviendrons longtemps
et
on
nous sommes des batwa des plus cléments
d'exit
nous vivons dans le malheur personne ne
nous a jamais d ici bas mais on vit avec
l'espoir
heureusement qu'il nous reste l'espoir
est ce que notre sort intéresse
quelqu'un sur cette terre qu'il soit en
france à paris ou en amérique ou
n'importe où dans le monde nous sommes
un grand peuple
on vient même nous étudier mais les gens
c'est servait nous et s'en vont et à
l'arrivée rien les chances pour nous
je